lavable et réutilisable et made in
france ces masques grand public sont
prêts à être distribués aux habitants de
villeneuve saint georges
ici au centre intergénérationnel arthur
rimbaud
les habitants sont rassurés de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un masque c'est nécessaire
et c'est quelque chose là gakic on
devrait tout le monde est en pente et
parce que ce concept est soi-même tout
elle aussi les autres et du montage
parce que j'ai été très recommandée par
monfils qui meuble comme un culte aux
commandes et il ya plusieurs semaines
ces protections sont livrés petit à
petit aux départements au total plus d'1
5 million de masques seront donnés au
val de marnais par leur conseil
départemental
une initiative qui vient compléter les
commandes des villes les villes on fait
parfois de leurs propres commandes
également de masques mais elles ne sont
pas toutes livrées aussi en même temps
et donc nous tenons compte de leur date
de livraison pour faire en sorte que le
masque du département puisse arriver au
bon moment quoi donc parfois en
anticipation quand les colonnes sont
tardifs pour les communes
c'est le cas ici
les neuf sages orge de son côté la
mairie a commandé 40 mille masques qui
distribueront gratuitement à ses
habitants à partir de cette semaine les
personnes vulnérables et âgées recevront
ces protections en priorité on va les
envoyer aussi à 500 personnes avec qui
nous avons le contact quotidien
donc les personnes les plus vulnérables
à qui on va donc distribuer aussi ses
masques entre nous villeneuve saint
georges est l'une des premières communes
auxquelles les autorités départementales
livre des masques elle est aussi la
municipalité la plus pauvre du val de
marne